hi everybody
um
glad to have you all back
for our next to last installment of
theory of computation
today um we are going to embark on the
very last
big topic for the semester
and that is in some ways going to be
following on what we
started
a couple of lectures back when we looked
at probabilistic
turing machines
and probabilistic computation
and its associated class bpp
now what we're going to
discuss
is in some sense
a probabilistic version of np
and that's going to be a complexity
class called ip
which stands for interactive proof
systems
um and so we're going to present that
model
and look at a couple of examples
uh
i would
just like to say at the beginning that
the
this model is a very important one it's
really uh has been the starting point
for a great deal of
research
in complexity theory so we're just
really going to be touching on it but
there's a lot more that people have
pursued with this model and it's also a
connection in to the cryptography field
which also makes use of the interactive
proof system model in fact
some of the
genesis of that model comes out of
cryptography
where you're having uh
multiple parties either communicating or
in some ways
interacting
uh to achieve certain uh goals of
communication or
signing or passwords or or or what have
you so uh this is a both a an applied
area and also one that has a lot of very
interesting theory uh um associated to
it
so with that one we we're going to jump
in um and uh
start out by uh
making myself smaller
and
just do a an introduction i'm going to
introduce
the model or the the concept of an
interactive proof
with an example
and that example involves the
graph isomorphism problem
that's the problem of testing whether
two graphs are isomorphic
what we mean by two graphs being
isomorphic is that they're really just
the same graph
with one of them perhaps being
re-labeled or permuted
so that
they may look superficially different
they may appear with a different
sequence of labels or the nodes are
appearing in a different order
but
except for that it's really just the
same graph so i'm kind of illustrating
that here if you can see those two
graphs here which look different from
each other both on eight notes they are
in fact the same graph
as i can illustrate by a little
animation which will convert this one
into that one
so uh
the
um
[Music]
so the
two graphs um
these graphs being the same um they're
we call that isomorphic
so these are graphs g and h and they're
really the same graph so we we um call
them isomorphic graphs
and we
are
have an associated computational problem
called iso
which is
given a pair of graphs we'd like to know
are they isomorphic or not so the iso is
the collection of pairs of graphs which
are isomorphic
and
it's easy
to see that this problem is an np
problem
because
all you need to do in order to see or to
give a certificate that the two graphs
are isomorphic to each other is tell you
it's just to say which nodes in the one
graph correspond to which other nodes in
the other graph
um and then you all you need to check is
that the edge relationships are
consistent with that
mapping or that isomorphism as it's
called
um
so it's easy to see that the iso problem
is an np
and if you're not getting that make sure
you uh understand because this is the
whole first part of the lecture will be
lost if you don't understand this iso
problem
now the question of whether
you can test two graphs
being isomorphic in polynomial time
is not clear and in fact that's an
unsolved problem to this day
uh
and it's a problem that has generated an
enormous literature uh
there are hundreds of papers
on the graph isomorphism problem as it's
called um to try to uh resolve
um you know uh to try to see if one can
find a polynomial time algorithm and in
fact it was a very big result
just in the last 10 years where there
was a sub-exponential algorithm given so
that was more
than faster than the brute force search
approach but didn't get it all the way
down to polynomial now why is there so
much attention just to this one
particular np problem it's because
it's not known whether the graph
isomorphism problem is np-complete iso
is not known to be an np-complete
problem and that puts it into a very
very small class of problems in np
which are no not known to be either in p
or np-complete
it's kind of a curiosity that for np
problems
almost all of them have ended up being
in one side or the other
and in fact
um it's a
uh
um
in fact the
the um
i i think it's the only problem that
just involves graphs
that's not known to be either in p or an
np
um
so so i got a question here
what would be in between exponential and
polynomial for example i don't remember
what the the bound is but it's it's
something in the uh
in the range of n to the log n
uh
time complexity for the graphite some
more i might be getting that wrong um i
don't remember exactly what the bound is
but um
that's significantly better than two to
the n or some
some exponential amount of time but it
it's more than enter any constant so
it's more than any polynomial time
so um
another question uh of the same sort is
whether the complementary problem is in
np or whether whether iso is in co-np or
let's let's talk about it in terms of
the complement whether the
complement of iso which i'll refer to as
the non-iso problem whether that's known
to be in np so that's also not known um
in other words if i give you two graphs
and i ask you to show that they're not
isomorphic suppose they aren't
isomorphic and you go through the effort
of you know determining that by a brute
force search and now you want to
prove
that they're not isomorphic well that's
not
it's not known to be an np either so
there's no known
short certificate certificate of
two graphs not being isomorphic
we don't know how to do that either
but there's something that's very
interesting nevertheless
um
and
it has to do with the ability to for one
party to prove to another
that graphs are either isomorphic or not
isomorphic
so if you're just having like a prover
we haven't really been necessarily
formulating that this way so much in
this class but this is a completely
equivalent way of formulating the notion
of np whether you have a polynomial time
verifier an approver who can produce
certificates say it's a powerful prover
so um if you have a problem that's in np
approver can convince a polynomial time
verifier
that uh strings are in the language if
in fact they are so in the case of the
iso problem a prover can convince a
polynomial time verifier the graphs are
isomorphic just by exhibiting the
isomorphism
now
for the non-isomorphism case
we don't know that that problem's in np
but it's still possible
for approver to convince a verifier that
graphs are not isomorphic
if you change the rules of the game
slightly
um
so even though the non-iso problem
is not known to be an np
approver can still convince a polynomial
time verifier that graphs are not
isomorphic assuming they they are in
fact not isomorphic um provided
that
um
the prover and the verifier can interact
with one another so the verifier can ask
questions of the prover
and the verifier gets to be
probabilistic
so that's in this
in that's in sense in which i mean
that this notion is a kind of a
probabilistic version of np
okay so um
let me
show you how that's done
so before we jump in to the
uh to the method for
approver to um show a verifier that
graphs are not isomorphic
um let me let let's try to get a little
clearer on the model so i'm going to
first show it to you informally and then
we'll look at it formally
okay so
in in interactive proofs there are two
parties
um
and i'm going to think about them as one
of them is going to be the professor
okay so the professor is going to play
the role of the verifier in a sense but
it's like that the one who checks
um
and uh the professor being kind of old
and tired he's been teaching too long
maybe
can only operate in
probabilistic polynomial time
so the professor if wants to tell
whether two graphs are isomorphic or not
probabilistic polynomial time doesn't
seem to be enough
to tell whether two graphs are
isomorphic or not because it seems to be
a more than polynomial problem
however
the professor
has
um
help
it has
an army
of
graduate students
and the graduate students
they're not limited uh in the same way
the professor is the graduate students
are young
they
are energetic they can stay up all night
they know how to code
so
the graduate students
have unlimited computational ability
so that we're going to think of the
graduate students playing the role of
the approver because they're not
they're not limited in their
capabilities we'll assume
the professor on the other hand is
limited so the professor wants to know
if the two graphs are isomorphic
let's say whatever they are
um
can't do it by himself so he's going to
ask his students to figure out the
answer
and report back
now there's only one problem
the professor knows that students
uh
well in the old days they'd like to
party i guess these days they like to
play on uh
play computer games a lot
and so they're not really that eager to
spend all their time
figuring out whether graphs are
isomorphic
so he's worried that the
the students will just come up with some
answer and figure that he won't be able
to tell the difference
so the professor does not trust the
students it's not enough to he for the
professor to give the problem to the
students and just take any answer that
they're going to give the professor
wants
wants to be convinced
okay so
um
now
how could the students convince the
professor of the answer that they've
really done the work and figured out
whether the graphs are isomorphic or not
well if the graphs are isomorphic if it
turns out that the graphs were
isomorphic and the students figure that
out
then life is good
because what are they going to do to
convince the professor
they're going to hand over the
isomorphism and show yeah i mean they
are
you know those graphs really are
isomorphic and here's how the
correspondence works professor can check
oh yeah i i now not now i'm convinced
but suppose the graphs were not
isomorphic
what are we going to do then
um the students have figured out where
after night else the professor wants
wants to be convinced oh no what are we
going to do
well in fact we're going to engage the
the professor and the students are going
to engage in the following protocol
dialogue
what's going to happen is
now you have to make sure you're you're
this is critical to follow to understand
this little
part of the story here because it's
really going to set the pattern for
everything in today's and tomorrow and
to today's lecture and the and the next
lecture
okay so
we're going to engage in a following
interaction between the students and the
professor which is going to enable the
students to convince the professor that
the two graphs really are not isomorphic
so how is that going to work
this is a beautiful little uh thing by
the way
so the professor is going to take the
two graphs
and pick one of them
at random
because the two graphs g and h
um let's say they're not they really are
not isomorphic the professor doesn't
know that for sure that's what the
students claim the professor really
wants to not be convinced that the
students are right
um so the professor's gonna pick one of
the two at random
randomly permute that
uh that choice the one that he picked
and hand it over to the students
say okay
here is one of those two graphs randomly
scrambled
then i'm going to ask the students
which one did i pick
okay now
if the graphs were really not isomorphic
the students can check
whether that randomly scrambled graph
is isomorphic to either g or to h it's
going to be isomorphic to one or the
other
and then they students can figure it out
and they say oh you picked g or no you
picked h
as the case may be the students can
figure that out
but if the graphs were isomorphic
then that
scrambled version of g or h could
equally well have come from either of
them
and the students would have no way of
knowing
which one the professor picked
so that there's nothing they could do
which would be better than guessing
so if we do that a bunch of times the
professor picks at random sometimes
secretly of course the picks the grip
picks either g or picks h
and the students get it right every time
either the students are really doing the
work
and the graphs are really not isomorphic
or
the students are just incredibly lucky
they're managing to guess right let's
say a hundred times
so how the
the the professor randomly and secretly
picks grh uses this uses its probabilism
flips a coin
just a two-sided coin and says okay
sometimes if we're going to do g
sometimes they're going to do h just
completely at random
picks one or the other
and then with some more randomness
gets finds a random permutation of the
one that he picked and then sends that
over to the students and say which one
did it come from
um
i'm not sure okay so let's pause here
let's let's make sure we all understand
this because this is really important um
so i'm getting a question here how do we
i'm not sure what your question is um
okay so let me just say yeah the
professor's going to play the role the
verifier the graduate students play
they're all approver that's coming but i
really want to understand this protocol
here okay so how is the professor
picking the graph skin if you're
okay i don't you know picking the graphs
at random you have just two graphs
they're in part of the input uh the both
the students and the professor can see
the graphs
and the professors are just picking one
of them at random using a coin so i'm
not sure i understand the question there
could p and v engage in a protocol where
the secretary is on the prover side
instead
the question of revealing the
isomorphism i there is no why so i'm not
sure i understand this question either
um maybe we'll make this clear
you know if
for
for this little illustration
the professor
doesn't know the graphs could be
isomorphic or they could be not
isomorphic
and so uh the professor wants to be
convinced either way whatever the
students whatever answer the students
come up with we're going to shift this
into a problem about a um deciding a
language
next but right now i'm just trying to
give a sense of the how the model works
i want to move from this informal model
and now i'm going to formalize that in
terms of
model which will be deciding a language
okay so
so the interactive proof
system
model
we have two interacting parties a
verifier which is probabilistic
polynomial time playing played by the
professor in the previous slide
and the prover which is unlimited
computational power played by the
students in the previous slide
both of them get to see the input
which in the previous case
well
it could be for example the pair of
graphs
they exchange a polynomial number of
polynomial size messages so the whole
exchange
including the verifier's own computation
is going to be polynomial the only thing
that's not not not included within the
computational cost is the prover's work
which is unlimited
um
after that the verifier after the
interaction the verifier will accept or
reject
and we're going to define the
probability that the verifier together
with a particular approver ends up
accepting
as
you
look over the different possible coin
tosses
of the verifier
which could lead to different
behavior on the part of the verifier and
therefore different behavior on the part
of the approver
so over all the different possibility
possibilities for the verifiers
computation
we're going to look at the probability
that the verifier with this particular
approver ends up accepting and i've
written it this way this is the
probability of the verifier interacting
with the prover accepts the input
is just simply that
um and so we're going to work through an
example
we're going to
work through the previous example
more
precisely in a second
the class ip for interactive proofs
stands for it's the class of languages
such that for some verifier and approver
um
for strings in the language
the prover makes the verifier accept
with high probability
and here's the interesting part
for strings not in the language the
prover makes it except with low
probability but every there's no prover
which can make it except with high
probability
so there's no way to cheat
if you think about it in the case of the
graphic non-isomorphism
there's nothing you know
if
if the graphs were really isomorphic
and the students were trying to in a
devious way
prove
through that protocol that they're not
isomorphic they would fail because
there's nothing they can do
if the graphs were isomorphic
then um
when the
verifier the the professor picks one or
the other at random
um and scrambles it the students would
have no way of telling which one the
professor did so no matter what kind of
scheme they try to come up with
they're going to be out of luck
so
it's no mat for any strategy
for strings that are not in the language
for any s any prover calling that p with
a tilde to stand for a devious or
crooked
prover
for any uh possibly crooked prover
even that with working with the verifier
is still going to end up accepting with
low probability
so strings in the language there's going
to be an honest prover who just follows
the protocol
in the correct way which makes the
verifier accept with high probability
for strings not in the language every
prover
is going to fail
to make it accept with high probability
um
okay so that i mean the way i like to
think about it is that p tilde is
a possibly crooked proverb which is
trying to make the verifier accept when
it shouldn't because the string is not
in the language
it's like you know
it's like even you can think of this in
the case of um satisfiability
um
you know
you
a crooked prover might try to convince
of the verifier that the formula is
satisfiable when it isn't by by somehow
trying to produce a satisfying
assignment but that's going to be
impossible there's nothing any strategy
can possibly work when the formula is
not satisfiable if that's what the
verifier is going to check it's going to
be looking for that satisfying
assignment
okay
and by the way this is we're not going
to prove this but it's really going to
be proved in the same way you can make
that one third error that could that
occurs here
something very tiny
by
the same kind of repetition argument
okay
so let's see um
so why can't the prover in the first
case be crooked um
the prover in the first case would could
be crooked but that's not going to serve
the purposes um
you know what what we want to show
um
you think about it like we think about
np
for strings in the language there exists
a certificate there is a proof
that you're in the language
so if somebody is going to
not produce the proof
that's irrelevant
the question is if you look at the best
possible case the best possible prover
um
you know who's going to be able
we're asking does there exist a way to
convince the verifier that the um
string is in the language
so it doesn't matter that there might be
some other
uh
silly way that doesn't work we're just
looking at the best possible way
so the best possible way when you're in
the language is going to end up with a
verifier having high probability
when you're not in the language the best
possible way is still going to end up
with low probability
when when i talk about best possible i'm
trying to maximize the probability that
the verifier is going to end up
accepting let's continue um not sure as
clear as i would like but
um
maybe again we're going to we're going
to stick with that example because this
is a very uh
helpful example and to try to
understand the setup
and uh so we're gonna i'm gonna revisit
that previous example about
non-isomorphism but now in the context
of this
thinking about as a language
so we're going to take this
non-isomorphism
um
uh yeah
we're going to take the non-isomorphism
problem
and show that it's an ip so there's
going to be a verifier together with
approver which are going to make the
verifier accept with high probability
for strings in the language namely
graphs not ice being isomorphic
and
nothing there's going to be no way to
make the verifier except with high
probability for strings out of the
language therefore that's when the
graphs are isomorphic
okay um so the protocol is just gonna
we're gonna repeat the following thing
twice
you know i said in the previous case do
it a hundred times just to
help us think about it but actually
twice is gonna be enough to get the
bound we need
so the verifier is going to operate like
this in terms of this is the verifiers
in first
communicating
sending messages to the approver it's
going to randomly choose grh
just like what the professor did last
time
randomly permute the result to get a new
graph k
which was going to be which was
which is isomorphic either to grh
depending upon the choice the verifier
made
and then send that graph k
now the provers turn is going to respond
by the proof is going to compare k with
the two one of the both of the original
graphs it's got to be isomorphic to one
or the other
and it's going to report back which one
just going to say well you pick g no or
you picked h
because the prover with its unlimited
capabilities can determine that
um
and then v accepts if the approval was
right both times
um
and if the approval was ever not right
the verify says oh something's fishy
here because we know that the prover has
unlimited capability so could get it
right if you know um if there was if
this was an honest approver um and so um
if uh
if it's not getting it right then the
verify is going to reject
so if the graphs are not isomorphic the
proofer can tell which one it picked
randomly so therefore
if the graphs are not isomorphic the
verifier with that that honest prover
will accept with probability one
because that honest proof is always
going to get the right answer
which is at least two-thirds is what the
bound we need
uh we don't care about the space used in
answer to a question
um if
we were not in the language so g and i h
are not isomorphic
then there's nothing any crooked pervert
could possibly do
because it gets a graph
can't tell there's no way to tell
whether it came from g or came from h
um
so that crooked proofer would have all
it could the best thing you could do is
guess sort of a 50 chance advancing
correctly each time and only a 25 chance
for doing it twice
and that's why i did it twice in order
to get that error um
uh
to be small so there's only a 25 chance
of the approver getting lucky so that
would be an
error case
if the proof of just by chance picked
the right answer twice even though the
graphs were isomorphic so therefore
for the isomorphic case
the verifier interacting with
any prover is going to accept that input
with at most one quarter 25 of the time
which is less than a third so those are
that's just to achieve that bound
okay
so
let's let's answer some questions first
and then i'll try to um
uh
i'll ask you
you understand this so this it's i think
it's worth trying to understand this
model um of this interactive proof
system
it's a little little slippery i i
realize but um
if you just hold your hold on to your
intuition of the prover trying to
convince
you know of uh
you know a powerful prover trying to
convince a limited verifier
um
of
some
string being in a language
uh
you want the proven to be able to
succeed when the string is in the
language but fail when the string is not
in the language
yes we are going to somebody's asking if
the prover is identifying grh by brute
force yes the prover is going to use its
unlimited capabilities to determine
given k
whether it came from g or h
the um
the computational
cost of the approver is irrelevant for
this it's just like when we think about
a certificate
um you know for satisfiability we don't
talk about the cost of finding that
certificate
uh for np
for ip again we don't talk about the
cost of the prover running
so somebody's asking does the crooked
per prover answer just randomly or does
uh can the cr quick approver has have a
strategy the crooked perimeter can have
a strategy
now we're not we're assuming the crooked
approver is devious
but it's still going to fail
okay um let's do the check-in
suppose we change the model
so that the prover can watch the
verifier picking its random choices
so uh the verifier cannot act in secret
anymore but the the prover can watch the
verifier
now let's suppose we had the same
protocol that i just described
what language do we end up with is it
the same language different language and
what is that language
okay so
i want to hopefully
um
let's let's
it'll
give me some sense of how well you're
following me by how well this uh this
goes
yeah someone's asking about how this
connects up for example with np so we're
going to look at that
also in a second
okay so this is reassuring that most of
you i think are on the right track at
least for this check-in uh do we assume
p uses this access to guess right
what access p is not really guessing the
p is tr is actually i don't think a p is
non-deterministic or anything like that
p is actually trying to get the right
answer
and using its
computational ability to do that if it's
possible
may not be possible then there's nothing
you can do
okay so let's uh end this are you all in
two seconds left
please vote
vote now or never
okay ending
um
yeah so c is the correct answer here
if the prover can watch what the verify
is doing the prover can see
what graph the verifier picked right
from the beginning
and so the prover without having to do
any work
can say you know it proves looks over
the verifier's shoulder and says oh you
picked g
and now you're randomly permitting it
but i don't care about that i just i
know you pick g
uh so uh the
proof is going to respond back uh g even
if the graphs were isomorphic the proof
is going to be able to get the right
answer
kind of interestingly um
uh
you can make a you can change the
protocol somewhat um to make it uh that
even if the
prover
has access to the verifier's randomness
you can still achieve this but not with
the same protocol
um
so that's uh that's a separate question
um okay so let's move on here i want to
get too bogged down
okay here's another check-in um
uh
okay so
you have to tell me which of the
following
statements are true
as far as you know
now you have to think about a little bit
how this
these uh
relate
to um how np and ip or bpp
and ip relate to one another
okay
how are we doing on this
okay so we're gonna have to close this
pretty soon too
do the best you can
interesting okay
closing up shop
last last vote
okay one two three
there's one more person out there who
hasn't voted who voted last time oh well
uh
all right
in fact they're all true
um
let's see why is np contained with ip
contained in ip uh well many of you have
seen this already so let's just quickly
go through it um
[Music]
if we just had a deterministic v
um
you know the uh
you can
uh
maybe it's just
that that can be enough of deterministic
v
i think it's just going to be equivalent
but actually just to be doubly sure the
deterministic v and the approver just
sends a message to the verifier and then
checks it
that's the way we normally think about a
certificate for np
uh i don't think it's going to change
anything but should double check that if
the verifier can still ask questions but
i think as long as the verifier is
deterministic you're going to get
exactly np
here
um
and um
now how about bpp
well
there you don't even need approver
because the verifier is already
probabilistic
so
verifier can ignore the approver
and this one is a little tricky uh i p
containing p space because we haven't
covered that so there's no way for you
to know that unless you happen to read
ahead in the book but it's in fact true
um in some ways it's a little bit like
the proof that
uh
np
is contained in p space ip is sort of an
enhanced version of np
and you and there's just a basically a
uh a piece based brute force algorithm
that goes through the entire tree of
possibilities um of the verifier
exchange
verifier with exchanges with approver
and can uh determine that um the
verifier is either going to accept for
some approver or is going to end up
projecting for every approver um
so we're not going to prove this
statement but something good for you to
know anyway they're just a fact
uh but we're going to do what the
surprising thing
in reference to part c
is that the containment also goes the
other way this is the amazing
um uh
was is an amazing result
that
everything in p space
you can do with in ip
so this is ip is actually turns out to
be incredibly powerful gives you
everything up in p space you get i p
equals p space
so that says that any problem that you
can solve in p space like any of the a
game for example
um if you can imagine you know
formulating you know checkers or
chess
as a piece based problem which you know
depending upon some details of the rules
you can do because you know you have to
generalize it to an end by end board but
okay
let's not quibble um
uh then
uh
um
[Music]
we don't know which side has a forced
win in chess
um and even if somebody goes through the
effort of going through the game tree
um and determines that let's say white
has a forced win
uh there's no way for them to there's no
short certificate we don't know that
that problem is not an np
but
by
going through an interactive proof
an all-powerful prover
could still convince somebody that white
had a force
you know convince somebody in polynomial
time that a
white has a forced wind let's say in um
in chess
again little
uh stretching things because this is
you know you really need to talk about
this as an n by n not an eight by eight
but i think in this the spirit is is uh
fair
so um
okay uh so let's continue
so wha
when we're not going to quite prove that
that p base
is contained in ip we're going to prove
a somewhat weaker statement but very
similar
um
is that uh and historically came first
that co-np is contained in ip
so not only is np contained in ip but
we're going to prove that co np is
contained in ip and this actually has
most of the i most of the idea for the p
space being contained in ip and itself
it's just an amazing proof
a little easier
um
okay
and th this was done
if i'm remembering somebody's asking me
when how old is this it's something in
the 19 i think late 90s but i'm not i
don't remember but maybe early 90s i
think it's late 90s
when this was shown
so it's been a while now
um
okay
so
um
yeah so in terms of the relationship
with cryptography there were two
parallel threads
um that both independently came up with
the notion of an interactive purge
system
uh i was a little bit personally
involved with this
in in a way as well but but mainly that
the the there was one group in
cryptography
um working on this and there was another
group who was actually coming out of the
graph isomorphism world
working on it and they they came up with
two separate models one involving the
private randomness and one involving the
public randomness um and it was turned
out that was
that they're actually equivalent
um
and uh
it's an interesting story but
unfortunately we don't have time for it
uh so
why don't we move on and i'm gonna start
showing you how the proof that
co-np
is contained in ip
goes and what we're going to do is work
with a problem that's
almost like co p complete but um
going to be uh well it's going to be
this number sat problem we'll see the
connection with co-np in a second
uh
so cohen p
so it's supposed to be exactly k
satisfying assignments
fee comma k
is the set of
pairs where the formula fee has exactly
k satisfying assignments so really
that's a problem of counting how many
satisfying assignments you have in a
formula
um
so you know for
np you have at least one
um but i'm i want to know exactly how
many
uh so the numbers that problem is the
pairs formula and the count
so
um
and uh so if we define the count
number fee is the number of satisfying
assignments of a fee
then another way of writing this uh
number stat problem
is
uh
the pairs phi k where k is the number of
satisfying assignments of fee
so we're going to be using this notation
number fee a lot so just make sure you
get you got that notation this is the
number of satisfying assignments of that
formula
okay
and here's a definition i probably
should have given you earlier in the
term but better late than never um
uh so the notion that a language is np
hard
it's like
np complete
except without being
necessarily being in np
so this is just the reduction part a
language is np-hard or co-np-hard or
p-space hard or any of those other
classes that we looked at
if every problem in the class is
reducible to that language
but you don't know whether this that
that language is in the class
so we just call it np hard instead of mp
complete
so you could say
the language is np complete if it's hard
and it's in np
okay and so we're going to show that
this number set problem is co np hard
so everything in cohen p is polynomial
time reducible to number set that's easy
because what we're going to do is take a
co np complete problem
which is the
unsatisfiability problem the complement
of satisfiability and sure that reduces
to the numbers that problem
and that's easy because
a formula is unsatisfiable exactly when
it has zero satisfying assignments
so if you can tell
how many satisfying assignments
something has exactly
or you can answer the question you know
does a formula have exactly
a thousand
satisfying assignments if you can do
that in general then you can solve co
and p uh you can solve the
unsatisfiability problem by asking with
zero satisfying assignments
and that allows you to solve anything in
cohen p
okay
so we're gonna just work with this one
problem the number set problem and show
that that problem's in ip
okay
let's take a quick break
um
okay feel free to send me let me see if
i can catch up with some of the
questions that have been
cropping up here so if the approver
knows the random choices of the verifier
can it can flip the answer to make the
verifier reject
not sure what that you mean in the
context just of the graph isomorphism
problem or
um something in general i'm not sure
you'll have to explain sorry i'll
respond with a question mark what else
can i answer for you guys so i got a
question
might
if i p equals p space does that mean
that iso or the or non-iso might be um
in might be p space complete but no
that's not known
so we're about out of time
okay
let's continue here
[Music]
okay so this this is where we're kind of
getting
going to start to get into the meat of
things um
[Music]
and if you didn't quite understand
everything up till now maybe just try to
keep your intuition
about how do i
you know how does a powerful party
convince a
um a polynomial probabilistic polynomial
time party
of the number of satisfying assignments
exact number not
not at least but you won't know exactly
the number um of satisfying assignments
um so it could be zero for example how
do you convince that how do you convince
someone that there were zero assignments
and and and you know you can have an
interaction which does that and that's
not obvious at all
how you're gonna do that
um
uh all right
so um
okay so we're gonna have to introduce
some notation which i
don't hope this doesn't
cause heartburn here
uh
so
let's say
again here is the the
computational the language we're working
with number set
and we have
a fee where that has m variables
x1 to xm
now
here's our notation i'm going to if i
write phi with this
free phi of 0
that just means the formula that i get
by
plugging in 0 for x one
and leaving all the rest of the
variables uh alone
okay so i substitute zero for x one
where zero means false and one means
true as usual
and but that's it's going it's still
going to be some other formula but just
with that substitution
if i write fee 0 1 that means i preset
the first two variables to 0 and 1.
um
if i write fee with
a bunch of
preset values i'm just setting the first
i variables x1 to xi to some values
and leaving the other variables
as unset
so i'm calling the ones that i'm
nailing in there as i'm already saying
these are the presets
okay so this is just converting some
formulas into other formulas that have
somewhat fewer variables
all right
now let's recall that number notation
the number sign notation number fee is
the number of satisfying assignments
now if i say number fee of 0
that's the number of satisfying
assignments
when i've preset x1 to 0.
similarly if i preset the first i
variables
to some
values
and then i take i want to think how many
how many satisfying assignments subject
to those prefix presets i write it this
way
so i'm going to use this notation a lot
you have to understand this notation ask
if you don't none if you don't get it so
another way of writing it i don't know
if this is helpful but another way of
writing number fee of a1 to a i
remember we have m variables all
together
that means i take the
variables which i have not yet preset
um
and i allow them to range over all
possible zeros and ones and i add up
the
the formulas values for all of those so
there's a one every time i satisfy and a
zero every time i don't satisfy so i'm
adding up all the satisfying assignments
subject to these i presets
okay
so here are two critical facts about
this
number sign notation
first of all
if i preset the first i values to
something
now i can
in addition
set the next variable either to zero or
to one
and i get this
relationship
which is just simply a generalization of
the fact that
the total number of satisfying
assignments of the formula
is equal to the number of satisfying
assignments when x1 is 0 plus the number
of satisfying assignments when x1 is 1.
right they together have to add up to
the total number because x1 is going to
be the either zero or one
so that's fact number one
fact number two is that if i preset
everything
all of the variables so there are no
variables left then the number of
satisfying assignments
subject to that preset
of everything is just whether or not
i've satisfied the formula which is the
value of the formula on that those
presets
okay
both two simple facts but it's going to
be critical in the protocol i'm about to
describe
questions on this
i think actually i do have a question
for you
so let's just see
what do you think
just to check your understanding
okay
got about 80
getting this
um
i'm not sure that's good but uh
all right almost done
closing
okay
okay so uh yes a is the correct answer
you know if if there are nine satisfying
assignments all together and there are
six satisfying assignments where the
first variable is set to zero
then there's only three satisfying
assignments with the first variable set
to one because
nine has got to be equal to six plus
three
that's actually this fact number one
it's not going to be 15
this is not true either
so
it's just a
good
okay
okay so let's try to
with with that knowledge let's try to
see how we can put
number sat in ip
so this is not going to quite work
but it's really going to set us up to do
this to finish this next time
um
so
you might immediately see where this is
going wrong but you'll
you'll have to put up with it
because um
the setup is what's important
um
okay
so understand now here's the
here's the the setup we have
um
the input is a formula
and
a number
where that number is supposed to be the
number of satisfying assignments
you know it could be wrong and in which
case we're not in the language
um but if it's right you're in the
language
so the approver is supposed to convince
the verifier
that it's correct if it is correct
and it's not gonna it's gonna fail no
matter what it tries to do
if
it's uh not
correct so this is the approver is going
to send first of all
um
so
so the proof is going to send a claim
about the number of satisfying
assignments
going to send when i say this value here
this is what the prover
if it's honest is going to send the
right value of course the verifier does
not know if the approver is honest
but i'm describing how the honest
approver is going to operate and we'll
have to understand what happens if the
prover tries to cheat
so the proof is going to send the honest
proof is going to send the number of
satisfying assignments all together and
the prover verifier just makes sure that
that matches up with the input
if it doesn't match up with the input uh
the verifier is just gonna
you know you know the the verifier is
gonna not be convinced that the input is
um in the language
so it's gonna just uh reject at that
point
um
okay uh
then now the verifier says okay that was
very good that you sent me this how do i
know that's right
so what the verif prover is going to do
to try to convince the verifier that
this value was correct
is
uh
unravel that by one level by say well
you know there were nine satisfying
assignments all together uh six of them
were when the when x one is zero and
three of them were when x one is one
to verify what does the verify have to
check
that
these add up correctly when i preset x1
to zero and to one
it had better add up to the total number
of satisfying assignments
if that works out the verifier is happy
is still being it's still consistent
with being convinced that this k was the
right value
um
so um
the next step is
well the verifier says well how do i
know those two values are correct the
prover says okay well i'm going to prove
send
un unravel them one level further
then here's a number of satisfying
assignments when the next variable is
set to both possibilities for each of
the possibilities of the first variable
now if you're
understanding me
about what the prover is sending you
should start to be getting a little
nervous
because
something is i mean this is going to be
correct
but it's going to start it looks like
it's starting to blow up in terms of the
number of
amount of work that's involved and
that's actually a problem
but let's bear with that for the moment
let's just worry about correctness not
about complexity for the moment
so
the proof is going to now send the
number of satisfying assignments for
each of those four possible ways of
presetting the first two variables
and the verifier is going to check that
that was consistent with the information
the prover sent in the previous round
right by again checking this identity
here so then the proof is going to
continue on doing that until it's got
it's done that
through m rounds where m is the number
of variables
so at this point
the proof is going to send
all possible ways of presetting all of
the variables so that now there's two to
the m possibilities here
again this is hopelessly
not allowed but okay ignoring that
the proofer's got to use this at the nth
round to check what happens at the at
the previous round so that's when they
were m minus one values sent because
each one has one more
uh
uh you're extending the presets by one
so which using this to check that the
previous round was the values were
correct so it's looking for
um
you know the m minus one
presets
have to add up correctly um you know in
terms of the m the presets of m uh
values
uh for each of those ways of uh doing
those uh m minus one presets
and so now the provers send all of those
two to the m
counts which are by the way ones and
zeros because at this point we have
preset all of the
values of the variables and so there's
only one possible assignment at most
that there can be
and now
the verifier
the approver is done the verifier is
going to check
by itself
that these values make sense that these
values are correct
so it's going to do that by looking back
at the formula
so far up at this point the verifier has
not been looking at the formula it's
just been checking the internal
consistency of the provers messages with
each other
but now at the end the verifier is going
to take the messages these these values
that the approver sent for each of the
two to the m presets and see if it
matches up with what the formula would
do
remember that was the other sort of the
base case
of the the end the fact number two
um from the uh slider to ago
make sure that these agree
okay and now the verifier says well okay
if everything has checked out and all of
these are
are in agreement
then the verifier is
going to be convinced
that um
that uh fee had k satisfying assignments
but if anywhere along the way one of
these checks fails
the approver is not the verifier is not
going to be convinced and is going to
reject
okay so in a sense this is kind of dopey
you know you know we've just
i'm just kind of giving you a
complicated way of just counting up one
by one each of the satisfying
assignments of the formula and seeing if
that matches k
but nevertheless
this way of looking at it is gonna be
uh
help us to understand
um the way to fix this so
so bear with me for another minute on
this one
so
another way of looking at this which i
think is is particularly useful
is to think of
what happens
well okay
we'll get there in a second i want to
look at what happens if k was wrong but
before i do that let's look at the
i'm going to give a kind of a graphic a
graphical
view
of um
the information that the prover sends
and the and the verifiers actions in
this protocol so the the values that the
prover sending are going to be in yellow
so the
and the information that the verifier
has or checks is going to be in white
so the the verifier has the k the the
input value which is supposed to be the
number of satisfying assignments
and the prover
sends some value and the verifier checks
that this value which is supposed to be
the number of satisfying assignments
corresponds with k
so that's one of the checks it does
then the approver is going to send kind
of take to justify this value
it
um sends
the number of satisfying assignments
when you have
x1 set to zero
or set to one
the verify adds those up to give you
and it's supposed to equal the total
number of satisfying assignments and so
this is if you understood this protocol
this is just i'm writing it out in a
sort of a simplified way perhaps
okay
and so um
keeps checking that these things add up
correctly until you get down to
setting all m values in all two to the
impossible ways and now the verifier is
going to then check to make sure that
that equals
the what the formula would say
um
okay
okay so now
let's what happens
if
k was the wrong value
it did not agree with the number of
satisfying assignments
um
and
what does what happens now um
could the prover
what happens if the approver tries to
make the verifier accept anyway
so
um
so the only thing the prover can do at
the very first step would be to lie
um about
you know if the approver sends the if k
is wrong
and the proof approver sends the correct
value
for
the the the total count the verifier is
going to reject so i'm trying to see
is it could the approver try to make the
verifier accept what what happens
so the prover has to lie here and i'm
going to indicate that by
saying the approver is sending in
the wrong value
for um
uh the the total count
well if the proof is going to lie here
um
then
just like you know if you
you know you have a child
who um
tells a lie
and then you start you know as the
parent you start asking questions to try
to
see if the story is consistent
one lie is going to lead to another lie
um and that's what happens here
if the uh
in order to justify this lie
um the proof is going to have to a lie
in one or perhaps both but at least one
of these two values because you can't
have the two correct values adding up to
the incorrect value
because you have to think about what's
going on here
so if this is a lie that's going to
force a lie
at one of one side of the other one
level down which is then going to force
a lie
to propagate down and so there's a lie
at every stage is going to force a lie
at least in one
one place or another to propagate all
the way down to the bottom
and then at the bottom the verifier will
see
that the check doesn't work
as when it turns when it tries to
connect it up with the formula itself
and the form verifier will reject
okay so just a way of looking at this
um if the form if the value
if the input was not in the language
um so uh
but the problem is
that as i said that this is exponential
so how are we going to fix that so
just looking ahead to what we're going
to do on tuesday
okay let's see if there's any questions
here first of all
uh
okay yes i got a question should this be
should this be a minus i i purposely
made this bracket only go
not include the very last zero yeah
there's a total of m zeroes here all
together but the
i left out the last zero that's why i
said n minus one maybe it would have
been better to say m
okay so and you got another interesting
question here why can't we reject right
away if k is wrong
um
uh
well
the verifier is probabilistic polynomial
time how does the verifier know if k is
wrong
um
so it means or or or right
so
what we're trying to do is something
like you know like np where we have a
certificate but now we have this kind of
interactive certificate in the form of
disprover maybe that's another way to
look at it
um
where if you're in the language there
should be some way for the prover to
convince to get make you accept but if
you're not not in the language there
should be no way
for the proverb to make you accept
um
uh
so the verifier just can't
reject right away because there's no way
to tell how does the verifier know it's
going to start rejecting things when it
shouldn't if it's just going to be
rejecting willy-nilly here
um
okay how does the verifier need to
determine if the prover is
internally consistent instead of just
asking
so why does the verifier need to
determine if the approver is internally
consistent instead of just asking the
questions in step n plus one
yeah so maybe that's
because it looks like all of the work is
happening at the very end
um
but i'm really presenting this to you
as a preparation
for what we're going to do on tuesday
um so it's important to think about the
connection from each step to the next
each step is going to be justified by
what happens at the next step
until we get to the very end
so you have to just understand it for
what it is don't try to make it more
efficient yeah i realize this is kind of
dumb
um
good point we're not using the
probabilism here
um
and
moreover we're not really even using the
interaction here the prover is doing all
the sending the verifier is just
accepting at the end
yeah
this is we're not using the power and
we're getting a weaker result so let's
move on before we run out of time here
so how do we gonna fix this
so the problem is is blowing up
each to justify each stage where
each value
we're
um
needing to present two values which add
up to it
um
and that's uh good leading to a blow up
now it would be nice if we can do
something where each value was
supported by just a single value
at the next level
so we know here's an idea well you know
in order to understand to see that
uh that that this total count is correct
why don't we just pick at random either
zero or one and only follow that one
down
well the problem with doing that
is because
the the
the sequence of lies is could be just a
single path through this uh tree
and the chances you're going to find
that path
down to a contradiction at the bottom is
very low if you're just doing it at
random
um so just randomly picking zeros and
ones as as the as the one you're going
to justify used to justify the previous
value is not going to be good enough
so what
but this is what we're going to do
however the values that we're going to
pick
for um
for these random
um
inputs
are not going to be boolean values
we're going to pick
non-boolean assignments to the variables
which again just as with the branching
program case didn't make any sense
on the surface of it we're going to have
to make it make sense
and
we'll have to see how to do that on tues
in tuesday's lecture
okay so that's kind of the setup
okay
um
yeah so in a similar question why is
this any different from just
non-deterministically guessing the
assignments it's because of this we're
really setting the stage
okay so what we did today was we
introduced them the the model and
defined the complexity class
we can we did show this one in its
full glory we showed that non-iso is an
ip
really worth understanding this
uh protocol here making sure you
you're comfortable with that
and and also the the model itself
and so for tuesday's lecture we're going
to finish this up uh well we started
showing that number set as an ip which
is what we need to to do to prove co-np
is an ip
and we'll finish that
next time
which will be our last time
okay so that's it for today
i'll stick around for questions
so
a good question here why can't um
v just
reject if some of the checks are
incorrect yes v could as soon as
there's a check that fails we can just
reject at that stage
i'm just trying to argue that at some
point along the way if the input is not
in the language
there's going to be a check that fails
so i mean i said reject at the end but
yeah i mean
you could have rejected at any point
along the way
um
okay
um someone's asking for what what role
did i play uh so i did
my my own personal role in this i were
to which was twofold first of all i i
came up with the idea
uh of
well not the idea i came up with the
name
interactive proof uh
i remember when sylvia mccauley was
explaining this to me in my apartment
many many years ago he had a kind of a
little bit complicated and i don't even
remember what the protocol was for it
was not for something simple was
something involving uh prime numbers
and i said oh
that's a kind of an interactive proof
and it's and it it stuck from that point
on so
um that was one thing but the other
thing in terms of more mathematically
i my role was so uh
shafi goldwater and i approved the
equivalence of the two models the public
coin and the private coin version
um so that that was uh
my uh
my role in this back and when this was
all first coming out
approved it approved it on an airplane
on the way to a conference somewhere
so i think we're going to
notice any other questions
i think we'll head out take care
everybody
see one
see you on tuesday
bye bye
you